ccl
the reason for that increase is twofold
and we've started to use
more storage in that environment as we
start to digitize more and more of our
documentation
but the costs are also related to us
increasing our remote access capability
that we did through
the covers so we went we've got actually
more infrastructure in there to allow
that to happen
microsoft licensing has changed as well
and two reasons for that we've just got
more people now
accessing the microsoft product set and
the other main reason
is that we're moving to a product and i
don't know if you're familiar with it
microsoft teams which will now become
our telephony environment so it will use
for our
internal and external video and
voice calls and the other movement was
trapeze which is a
solution that's used predominantly by
our building unit
but our planning team are going to start
using it as well
now we bought that on a per user basis
but with the increase in numbers it was
more
made more sense to go to a site license
so the increases there
is moving from that user base to site
license
in terms of staffing we're retaining our
security specialist at the moment
and that security specialist is there
for two reasons
we've got an extensive cyber security
program which will
elevate the level of our maturity here
at the council
and they're also covering for a member
of staff who's on a long-term sabbatical
as well
and so that that's going to have an
impact next year with us
and now you may ask why i'm showing um
the projects when there's no actual
change to budget we've actually managed
to keep to that but there has been an
impact so what we've actually done is
we've looked at a program of work
and we've actually elongated some of our
projects so we've phased them out so
they'll
run over a longer period but in some
cases we've actually moved them into
later years
so for example we're going to have a
look at contract management
we are going to review our document
management system trim
but we've pushed these things out to
22.23
so in the commentary there was just a
list of projects
and i thought it would be useful for you
just to understand a little bit more
about some of these key projects
our e-services program it continues to
digitize some of our internal forms for
our staff but some of our
external forms for the community and
we're taking the opportunity when we can
to automate some of the processes around
that so
a good example of that is now our online
booking capability for
all the council facilities where you
can't you can it's one touch you go in
you book
you pay and it's reserved for you
interestingly we're doing a little pilot
with our friends and community
and recreations around
sensors to look at how we might be
utilizing one of our
parks and get some information around
that
we continue to develop our
asset management and information system
to capture more and more of our key
council assets
um we are certainly looking at things
like office 365
which gives um word
and excel in our powerpoint but in a
cloud format
um and we still continue to move on rga
on the gis front enabling more and more
location-based
information as well
um i just thought i'd mention a couple
of things um
that will probably continue to impact on
the budget
areas within it and you may have heard
of software as a service or cloud
and whether we like it or not the
vendors of solutions now
are moving more and more to offer their
products only in the cloud
and and that fundamentally changes the
way we procure things because we're
buying a service and no longer buying
physical assets
so we need to keep an eye on that and
manage that well
and the other thing that we
unfortunately have to live with is
is cyber security
more and more we've seen hackers hacking
organizations just because they can
as well as obviously for financial or
political gain as well
and so we need to keep mindful of
trying to reduce the probability of
attack
but we also have to understand how we
would minimize impact
and and if you look at some of the
researchers that will say when we're
attacked not if we're attacked so
we've got to be able to and capable of
doing that the little graphic there
sorry it's small graphic but if you look
at the blue bars that's indicating
um the number of cyber incidents that
were reported through
cert nz an agency that helps
organizations and businesses with cyber
security
and and that was for the first half of
and the red bars are showing the
corresponding same period
for 2020 and they're saying that they've
seen a 42
increase in the number of attacks that
have been uh logged with them now
so it's there with us i think it will
always increase and we've just got to be
ready for that
so that's some of the key points and
more than happy now to answer
any questions that you have with regards
to the budget
thanks andy that was really
comprehensive and
appreciate the effort you put in there
so it's great
so um any questions from colleagues
it's pretty comprehensive kirsten
hi andy how are you going um just
just overall when you're in your budgets
um
obviously you've had to prioritize the
projects coming forward but how much are
going to benefit
customer services in terms of the front
the public in terms of the front-facing
i.t solutions and where are they sitting
on the budget what years
okay um that has we've
had a strike a balance there is some
work that we need to do behind the
scenes to make sure that we've got the
right
capabilities to deliver some of that and
then the key ones are probably around
the internet of things that i mentioned
briefly there how we are actually going
to start consuming an awful lot of that
data to give us better insights
into how our community are consuming our
services
and what we might have to do either to
improve them or adjust them on that
basis
and the e-services program is
predominantly
helping in that community space as well
so with other areas that we're looking
at are things like dog license and then
how we can improve that whole
experience for our community as well so
there are a number of things that are
going on there
i think a lot of the things that we are
looking at are
indirectly will help so the the
the capture of assets with in our new
system
um is actually helping in the background
service that we're delivering around
things like in you know water break
fixes because we understand more about
what's in the ground now as well and we
understand what we're going
to see so these are the kind of things
that are there so i think everything has
an impact probably on our community but
either in an indirect or
direct way
i think what also you'll see is the
website redesign
and already we're doing quite a lot of
stuff online at the moment
what customers are looking to do
business with us
and that'll be a lot more easier
to locate and use so at the moment it's
quite
cumbersome trying to get through to the
area you want to get through to
and i think some of the structure that
i've seen alistair working with at the
moment will work quite well for us as
well
so in previous years we've talked about
being able to log in and have your own
account and do that
we haven't really promoted it because we
haven't been ready with
back back services how is that
developing because it's just
it seems to be taking a very long time
to get to a
reasonable level of service for the
people who want to now do everything
online and basically do everything on
one of these
i think we'll just i think we'll just
have to continue to look at how we're
delivering some of that through our web
services
and but you're right and our customers
are starting to become more okay with
mobile applications
and at the moment one of my key
objectives
is to review the business improvement
strategy which has just come to
a a it's an end of its first period and
we'll obviously be looking
at that in terms of how we can digitally
transform
and going forward some of these services
that we are delivering so
it's certainly up there as a number one
for me to have a look at that and
obviously coming out the back of that
will be a programme of activity to
tackle that any other questions
well thanks andy no problem how we
at the start of the meeting we had a pro
forma motion which included all the
budget
papers as they are so if unless there
was any
debate sure other things colleagues
wanted to amend them that the budgets
will go through as
in the draft budget as is presented so
thank you for all the preparation and
work that you've done and we look
forward to working with you
well nice to meet you i think
sorry
is it not dumb it was a good it was a
good try
that's the property budget
thank you thanks andy appreciate it if
there's any
questions that come up after the meeting
thank you appreciate it
okay thank you
step up this year so thanks andy
um appreciate it we look forward to
working with you thank you
okay so we're now um you can remain
there rob if you like
now i get uh sorry not much
we come to rob page 636 and the whites
good afternoon mr mayor councillors
so jeff consider we've read this so it's
uh
wrong sorry it's been a long time yeah
um so we've read this so just highlight
the main points that you feel that we
absolutely know thank you um probably
some of those key points
the housing rent review deferred for one
year as a result of government changes
you will recall that the july
rent increase was put on hold as a
result of coping 19
and subsequent to that legislation
changed meaning you could only do a rent
review once every
12 months so for a number of reasons
the the better alignment to the annual
income adjustment for pensioners
and some additional financial support
they get from the government in terms of
heating
subsidy that all happens in sort of
april may june sort of period so
there's some additional funds and and we
feel that that's a
probably a better time to bring in a
wrench
increase in july as opposed to november
there's certainly some additional
administrative costs if you
uh have your budget split um in terms of
both revenue expectations and the
associated costs etc and
so having another 1st of july makes a
lot of sense from a
process point of view the steep rent
increase
to now apply um from years two to four
with one year extensional extension and
uh that's intended to preserve our
financial position
um over the 10-year horizon so to return
us to
where we where we would otherwise be if
we didn't have the
impact of these changes so that's
probably a key one
additional office accommodation in the
form of durham house
and has been allowed for over the next
10 years the lease is for three years
plus one plus one but we anticipate
the likelihood of us extending that
beyond that
through to the anticipated extension of
the office building in
2028 29 and the following year
um i'd just like to note that there's
some uncertainty around the scale
um the footprint and the nature of the
office extension
and it's largely due to the three waters
review and
and what the outcome of that and will be
that will obviously have an effect
um and and also the scale footprint and
nature of both the library extension
uh and the public amenity and car park
space
as well as the potential for other um
activities
on that that site um and as you'll be
aware there's a
um a steering group form that's working
their way through
those considerations and and they are
still in progress
there's some new provision in the budget
in relation to the kaiapoi mixed
use business area to cover off on
holding costs
and some anticipated expenditure on
valuations and and the like um where we
do look at proposals for either leasing
or um for disposal within that
and um there's an update report or
reports coming to the february council
meeting
and covering off on progress on the
three coastal campgrounds
those probably cover off the main points
but i'm very much open
to any questions thanks robert just
just one point um with the increase of
the housing for the elderly
what we normally do is we have to give
them three months notice of that
increase
and so we normally go out about the same
time as we go up consultation
of the ltp and just give them a bit of
an advanced warning
and what that does is sometimes we get a
little bit of feedback
through the consultation process not to
increase them
so that's just what we normally do
uh catherickinson rob just with the um
regeneration land that we've got there
the mixed business use
you've got the rates in here where does
the maintenance budgets fit for that
does that sit with you or does that
still sit with recreation no that's it
because i'd like to know
yeah a holistic cost of what's it's
actually costing in in a holding cost
so who who does that or where does that
sit that that has come over to me
to administer um
there's a i guess there's a a logical
question of
in terms of the maintenance well what is
the maintenance is likely to be
maintaining the grass and
keeping it well kept and aligned uh and
while that's likely to
be through um the delta contract um that
doesn't necessarily mean to say that
it has the the asset ownership titular
asset ownership
needs to sit with green space or
something else so
the logic behind it is that given the
commercial nature of it
and the likely sale of the property
we're the preferred one to administer
but there are clearly a number of other
stakeholders within
council's administration the business
centres are a lead on that
and so we're really holding it in terms
of holding cost rates and
maintenance and and providing some
support around
the sale processes or leasing processes
so is the
maintenance cost in the budget though
that's covered within
the allowance so it's not a lot um at
the moment
it's really allowing only for
maintain keeping the grass maintained so
there allows my question
if it's just as a holding cost
without maintenance whereas the rain
wants cost
6 45 645
uh at the bottom of that page uh you see
mixed business use areas there's an
opera
ops budget of twelve thousand and a
maintenance budget of two oh i see i was
a mistake but backside thank you thank
you
thank you uh rob just a question social
housing
where where where are we at with that
review and process please
um there we have been doing some work in
the background
it's not as progressed as we would like
to have done but
we're looking at over the next six
months um bringing that back to council
in terms
of the strategic direction and
where we might apply the funds from the
proceeds of this
it's been a very long time and i get
asked about it constantly
is there any way that that can be any
sooner than six months place
like within the next month or two we can
certainly bring um
an update on the direction i appreciate
it if you could continue with rob on
that because
you get asked a lot of questions about
it i should i should know this is not
going to be my area from the first of
february on
it'll be it'll be underlies
um but i'll keep an eye on it um when
you talk about social housing
it brings a number of bells with me in
terms of what that strategy looks like
we have housing for elderly we don't
have social housing
and so it's different niche markets that
you look looking at and even
even within housing for elderly there's
niche markets you know
such as the um the air beliefs for
instance
they look after a sort of a commune type
yes sort of housing for elderly
as opposed to the niche market we look
at
and it's more traditional blue collar
worker
rented most of their lives and that and
so
um and we don't do the heavy touch
um social housing that come through your
traditional
housing corporation so
through greater christchurch partnership
in particular this is an issue that is
that is gaining momentum and
uh both social and affordable housing
and the council's role
in well affordable housing has a number
of components to it
as as you would be familiar from you
know from how do you get people into
home ownership through making
development affordable
through people is there adequacy in the
rental market for
the needs and as their uh capability
between the private sector the ngo
sector
and the public sector to be able to
deliver that what's the various roles
with
entities like order who are now the main
provider for
social housing across new zealand
in the greater christchurch context
there's a fair challenge being put to us
that this
that this area and selwyn should accept
a greater
share of the responsibility in
supporting
social and affordable housing across
greater christchurch and not leaving it
solely
to christ church or predominantly to
christ's huge city
that's an interesting debate i think
there will also be a debate about the
future
ownership of elderly persons housing
whether that should remain in the
council domain
christchurch have put it into a trust
with
initially the motives were i think
around gaining access to funding
particularly government funding that
previously wasn't available to
local government interestingly there is
still
you know the whole housing issue clearly
is
one of the hot potatoes of new zealand
at the moment and it's only going to get
hotter with
the way property prices are heading so
you're right to note that it is going to
become a significant item on the agenda
and this council
thinking about how it positions itself
how great at christchurch positions
itself and the relationship between
the public sector providers ngo and
private sector what's the right balance
and what
role should we play is an issue that is
in front of us
right now yeah and jim's absolutely
right i get asked by you
and others of us on the greater
christchurch committee been asked by
yani okay we've got our district plan
that we've um the land with our partners
and it's a really key
question so we had a consultant come in
well over 12 months ago
that helped us pull information together
i really would like to see this sooner
rather than later about where
some options for us to consider because
we've sold down most the housing and
odds for the state now
i've said this to the partners when
we've talked about it that we've got a
plan coming and we'll be talking about
it we're still talking about it
so i'm just putting on on record by
disappointment that we haven't got
something here
already and i would like it sooner
rather than later please
okay so other questions about council
barnett
council award council
right thank you for answering my
questions but i'm sorry i still didn't
understand one of them so i'm just going
to
ask a little bit more on page 650 with
the
pence pensioner housing
budget the very bottom line
is closing balance and
from 20 all the way through it's getting
worse and worse and worse and we
said there's no sign of improvement what
does how am i reading that wrong um
can you explain that because i thought
it shouldn't it should at least be
coming back
it is it is coming back um you can see
uh and i'll point you to the the
operating surplus line you can see that
the operating surplus
um sort of on the on that page
the fourth green line up oh yeah so it
does start getting better
and it continues to go into the black
and what that means is uh you're
actually covering your operating
expenses what we could do with this
account is just take out a big loan and
close that account off
right off the line and the uc interest
principle come through
as we do it for most other accounts this
one it doesn't have any rate
funding it's purely funded by fees and
charges
in year 17 it goes into the black
in equity its equity goes into the black
and from there on
it builds up sufficient uh reserves to
actually
fully fund our ongoing uh
capital replacements uh you know
renewals work
because when i looked at the capital
surplus that's getting worse and worse
too yeah
so that didn't seem to line up we can
provide an ex
everyone else year 20 for you and it
does just extrapolate and show you that
it does recover
so we'll send that through if you
imagine also the
the the line of the rent is going and a
gradual increase
and we have a 10-year period where we
are
actively spending significant life cycle
money on doing the upgrades
once that capital expenditure stops
then the capital account actually then
starts to go into the opposite direction
and grow and and once it gets into the
positive in 2037 and it grows
substantially
and you are earning interest on that
money as well so there's an inflation
edge which positions us to make it quite
nicely going forward
thank you the other thing we haven't
done this year is we haven't
put in front of you uh the increased
effects
and we try and work what that is because
sometimes when we put an increase
uh in fees to the um for housing
creality they actually get more
disposable income
because the accommodation supplement
puts them in a different threshold
so we haven't done that this year but we
need to actually uh
see what what that is because we know
councillor cabane comes back and asks us
is it affordable so yeah
but sometimes it gives one or two
dollars in your hand a week
by putting the rent up it's quite a
strange situation
and just subsequent to that with all the
new landlord regulations
are we meeting those standards because i
know that some of those properties still
even though they've been upgraded the
standards aren't quite high now
so they're healthy so there are certain
parts of the standards or expectations
around things like insulation
they are all squared away uh
yeah and around asbestos management with
that's part of the program of capital
works is
working our way through addressing that
and
when we come to um the those
refurbishments that also addresses
the vast majority if not all of the
healthy homes standard
expectations there are parts of what are
commonly referred to as healthy homes
that are legislative and parts of them
are aspirational so i think we need to
understand subtly the difference
but there is also a
subtle point whereby if there's an
existing tendency in play
then the standard
for certain things doesn't apply
and that's not to say that we want to
disadvantage existing tenants
but from a practical point of view of
undertaking the refurbishments
if we were to do it on all of the units
in one go to try and get them up to
standard you would put an awful lot of
people in hotels and
at a considerable expense so it's
counterproductive
so as we get vacancies from people
moving on or
whatever that's when we are we have the
program of doing those refurbishments
which
address those those things and picks up
on a new tenant coming in
so that we're compliant when
entertainment starts so that's that's
the direction that we're working on
council award thank you
um page 643 um
with service center um expenses
and lease farmers lease says 280.150
durham street 97 810
but i can't find where where um percival
street or junction hotel which are new
leases
where they are proportioned as their
expenses
and so they aren't allowed for in the
ltp because we will
be completing the refurbishment
prior to those
prior to the new um area coming to play
so our need for those spaces will will
go
though only durham is the permanent one
the other two are true temporary
okay so we haven't taken long-term
leases on the junction hotel or
this was because we know okay thank you
council redmond thank you
my one of my questions you've just
answered i wonder
about the building unit in the junction
hotel
and the esu and the percival building uh
that personal
building is very handy you get your
lunch downstairs and going
[Laughter]
so never mind that'll have your
inconvenience
they are sweltering today though
right uh my question was on page six
three
seven the inability to have a rent
increase for the elderly
it seems that the knock-on effect is
a figure of four million dollars by year
if that's carried forward so if if we
didn't address it
the gap would be in the order of the the
gap between the existing rental flow and
the adjustments
because incrementally every time you if
you make an adjustment this year you've
already made that
for the subsequent years so each annual
adjustment on the step rent
to get you to a sustainable level
actually runs through
for the for the 10 9 8
7 etc so it actually accumulates to
quite a substantial
sum we missed out on one increase can we
double up
on the next increase
the strategy we've used is to add an
extra year
to it we could do exactly as you say
what that does
tend to do is steepen the rent increase
and and when you allow for the net
impact
on that not all tenants and jeff makes a
good point that some tenants ironically
are almost
better off with rent increases which
seems
perverse but for many of them
there is 30 of the rent increase
they carry themselves and 70 is covered
by the increase in the accommodation
supplement
um so if we if we concertina that then
there's a more significant jump so this
is spreading it
which one view is that that is
a more gentle and
less of a negative impact on people
adjusting to the change it is a moot
point because we
certainly could do it as you say to
increase in the three-year
step rent more um or do it the way that
we've proposed here
well i think what we do we'll do is we
will model it and because
i'm expecting an increase in this
accommodation supplement because with
housing prices going up the government
will have to
arrange an upward movement with not just
the rates rebate but
other things particularly as the rental
housing
accommodation supplement so we'll have
to model that and
see how that looks when we do put it up
quite significantly
we have to go around and have special
meetings with the
um the elderly because they get quite
upset about it
we have to actually explain to them and
we normally bring some of them from
uh one's wins to actually uh support
that discussion and we usually get a
couple of counsellors in as well
but we will model that and just see what
it looks like
because it's probably we're probably
going to get a win-win situation if that
does happen
well the rent freeze was a covert sort
of response but yet the elderly
class and myself are the least affected
because they will have a guaranteed
income your income hasn't been impacted
but anyhow i look forward to seeing what
you come up with
thank you um council reckons thank you
mr
can i say that those um those
meetings that we've had in the past is
extremely successful
the elderly actually really appreciate
them
i sit through yesterday snapseed solve
of the condition of runway muse
and the common gardens edges hedges and
so on that are actually in my view quite
disgusting
um and so then from there i wandered
around to
to meadow street to have a look and the
weeds around there are equally
in the common gardens have we got in
these budgets
enough maintenance money because that
prompted me to come back here this
morning
and look at these budgets and go man if
that's mowing for 12 months and that's
gardening for 12 months they are
extremely low
and i want to make sure because believe
me my mother lives at random
news and that was how i saw it in the
first place
when those elderly are sitting in their
chair in their veranda
looking at weeds that becomes the
biggest problem that will cause them a
heart attack
in the next 24 hours that you've ever
seen and believe me when i go in there i
get accosted by
i think there's uh 19 units and the area
i get accosted by 15 of them because the
other four are in hospital
um it's saying look at the condition of
these now
the reason i ask this is it it would
appear to me
on value that there is not enough
maintenance money in here
to do the gardening at these at these
units they are ours and we need to be
looking after the elderly
and we need to make sure that it is
adequate in my view
and it just appears to me there's not
enough money in there rock can you
i mean you will have assisted i know but
i just can you give me some assurance
that it is there
it is enough right um
some of the the contracts that we
did have in play around the garden
maintenance
have lapsed and we have been working
initially we were working
with the delta to look at
tying in with their existing contract
they came back to us with
a quite a different price to what some
of the others were signaling
so we've decided to take that out to an
open procurement
and we're actually working through
establishing the standards because
you're quite right there are some areas
where we feel that the contract that
has not necessarily served us as as well
so
i'm i'm a bit concerned around some of
your comments because i hadn't had quite
that level of feedback
and i will certainly follow up on that
with gene and
and also go and have a good look myself
but the detail and the specifications of
the earlier contracts
were not what i would call adequate um
to give us teeth to
enforce so that might be pointing to uh
a cost um issue um or it may be just
around a performance
um aspect in relation to the contracts
um as such so
we're hoping that with the new contract
form that we want to put in play
that will address the standard and
through a competitive
process we also hope to get a reasonable
good price but that will obviously
evidence itself once we go through that
in the first instance however
i certainly will follow up on those
comments
because i didn't get the sense that they
were quite as bad as what you've
described so
well look thank you for that but it
would have been nice to have that
indicated and here i had no idea
that there has been changes in level of
service but my second question to that
is so what do we do in the interim
they're like that now so how do we how
do we get them up to speak
right now so that we can keep the
maintenance up because my understanding
is around here and believe me i do have
a little sort of list
is that they're going in their mowing
the lawns are not doing any edges
they're not doing any common gardens
because that's what they've been told to
do
that's
i do need to go away and clarify some of
those points
yeah um with exactly where thank you so
um i'll do that investigation thanks any
further questions
all right thanks rob that's your budget
unless there's any comments any
colleagues wish to make
thank you all right
um we now moved uh not that
james farmer anywhere yes management
budget
no he's left left the building
okay
so we're at
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i was going to the right page um 665.
yeah i was going to say 666 but
this budget covers the chief executive
and the ea support that is provided
across the organization
there was a little adjustment in this
coming year's budget for presentations
which are
long service leave when jenny went
through and said how many are going to
get
long service leave at the end of this
long service presentations and
and what goes with that there's actually
a bump so she reflected what
uh the reality is rather than running at
a deficit
um
he would say that after his budgets are
finished can we
can we recall please have a look at it
so i um you know i've been i'd be uh
i'd be saying pretty much nothing to see
in that budget
but happy to take any questions uh any
questions from colleagues
no thanks jim okay awesome
[Laughter]
that's my code that's my code name for
the council
all right in fact you know it's just
just to be serious for a sec that is
actually one of the best
value spins we do and you know people
who come along for things like the mad
tri
uh later this week get to see the work
of that team put together
and makes a they do some things which
are fun
uh across the organisation so
is there a reason for that not
from my perspective there's not so you
mean the mad try yeah
well because you were into teams and
stuff for a
i suspect it's just yeah i suspect it's
just uh
uh the email address has picked up an
email address that's got staff on it but
yeah you're most welcome and a late team
would be uh
you could be registered from this point
you could train tomorrow
and you'll be ready to go for friday
yesterday
[Laughter]
yeah yeah no no look
making a difference
oh well there's something we can look at
for next year i did see david
on his e-bike this morning so he could
probably do the bike leak for you
right here well yeah
[Laughter]
let's keep moving okay so so the last
budget for your consideration yep
um and it's uh
six seventy seventy is close enough
so there there is a a significant
increase in here and i have mentioned
this to you before about
us employing a human resources manager
both to enable liz to take some
leadership in other parts of the
business that
i've talked to you about before and
really to give us capacity
to deal with the number of challenges
we're facing both the growth of the
organization
the issues that manifest uncertainty and
tension in our community and across our
organization
translate to a significant amount of
work for
our hr team which are struggling to deal
with that let alone the other business
they should be focused on
and the other element is there is just a
whole lot more to come so what happens
in
the reform proposals that are coming um
helping the organization through that
significance so that has been
um the the reason for that
increase in cost otherwise it's being
kept
as tight or as close to last year as
possible
okay any questions so jim
phil
employee assistance program
it is a great program so employee
assistant is through
uh workplace and they they do
a number of things for us firstly uh we
have
they used to be called industrial
champions but they're not that anymore
but andy
edwards comes to our place
uh walks and walks the floor talks to
people about issues
and that that's hugely valuable because
he builds relationships
over time with staff and when they have
concerns and we allow
people you know whether they're personal
issues or
work related issues we allow we provide
support
and at times staff may need counselling
so we will provide
a a number of paid for counselling
sessions to support staff through
difficult
times it might be health related family
trauma work stress issues
work relationship issues we provide that
support and they do it
they also help staff who are going
through some
difficult times trying to work out
where their place in life is and whether
it's here or not and
and they'll support them through that so
that's a really
valuable part of our of the services we
we get and offer and support staff with
and it makes a huge difference that
service is also available to you
absolutely so is i indicated through
code
well it seriously that's it and andy
drops into my office from time to time
he sits down for a chance he's a
really lovely guy and it's just nice to
know that we have
someone offering that pastoral support
within our organisation because
sometimes if you're going through
something you need someone that's
independent can talk to and
i've not i can't speak to myself i
haven't used the service but just in him
sitting down and uh and the way he deals
with things and certainly through
yolanda's passing last year too he was
great
really good to someone to sit down and
he comes from a very caring background
of his career he's a lovely man so we're
really lucky
and we have they have wider councillors
that are available
to support as well
the doubling of legal fees with more
than double of it
okay let's see i've gone from eight
thousand
uh eighteen thousand three hundred yeah
and will probably reflect a number of
the issues that we have in front of us
where
we need legal advice
and support the
employment law field is i would only say
getting more complicated
and i i think that is just reflecting a
reality of the level of
fee that we actually have a really good
hr lawyer penny shaw
is our who's a independent operator
and she gives us really good service and
advice but
you get some uh you only need two or
three
times a year to get a challenging
employment relations issue and
and she's available to deal with those
but she also gives us quite a lot of
other general advice and support so
um uh yeah
that's that's the reflection of probably
the level of business that we
do and probably anticipate to do if i'm
being honest
so we're having a few legal problems
with that
um we look in a business like ours
um probably at any point in time we have
one or two
things going on at any one point in time
you know that's just the way it is
people i would say people are more
litigious these days too they are
they're more knowing of their rights and
are prepared
to um and that's not a bad thing but it
is just a effective life and
when they turn up with a barrister or
something like that
for a performance review you know
sometimes you know or
a performance discussion or something
like that which happens
in um sometimes we need
matching support um
yeah i don't think we should go any
further into that we're in a public
nation
so got any specific questions we could
have that in the briefing at some stage
we just turned sandra would you mind
turn the microphone off down here
all right any further questions all
right
so i think that's us done do you want to
give us
a call oh sorry what else do we got
today oh yeah sorry
i'm meaning in terms of their pages yeah
so the thing left to do is make your
resolution and adopt them
yeah yeah
so the decisions that have been made
subject to this resolution have had some
impact on the
rate proposals that we were saying so we
were at
three nine three nine four and then some
four twos
so with your decision yesterday around
enterprise north canterbury that was
another thirty thousand so that would
take
year one from 3.9 to 3.95 and today's
decision
around bringing forward
the ravens would land
provision of two two and a half million
bring that forth from
24 25 through to 21
22. well
if it's 21 there's a 20 but there's 21
22 so that'll actually have an effect
from the 22
okay so you've probably got a
uh
yeah so there's a little bit so we've
probably got
at least two 3.95
then a little bit of a blend and extend
on the 4.2
so whether the 4.2 you know i'm not sure
how
the first time before i spoke so it'd
be 3.95 4.15
and then 4.2 4.2 4.2 4.2
that's what the essentially the
decisions that
have been made today so 3.95 4.15
4.2 4.2 4.2 4.2 so
we need a resolution to adopt and
confirm
all budget reservations so i'll move
from the chair that we do so
second council duty so just just briefly
speaking today but i think we've had a
really
good couple of days it's been really
good discussion uh here
thank you to our staff because i really
genuinely mean that our budget papers
are the best i've seen in my time on
council
there's a few things in there there
always is but i think from last year
particularly
this has been a dramatic improvement and
we were
in lockdown last year too so sarah the
governance team
thank you for all the support that
you've put into making sure that
the papers were out to us early so there
was
an opportunity for that to be considered
i think the process that you also put in
place
following some feedback from last year
that all colleagues
that put in questions could see the
answers in advance
if they had had time to do so appreciate
that doesn't work for everyone but it
gave that ability to see what the
questions were because you may well have
answered that yourself
and ask that oh we're going to ask that
it just takes up a lot of staff time not
knowing who's asking who's doing what so
i thought that process that you put in
the place is really good to the
um we've got an lttp team
uh at pcg um so elaine's out of there
thanks elaine for being here jones part
of that as well
jim and jeff superb advice as always
and i think we're landing in a
responsible position to present to our
community
so and all that all our staff that are
presented here i think they've done
super well
and commended them on that throughout
the process as
as have we all to get through this in a
couple of days there's been a lot of
previous work this last uh period of
time so
thank you all for your involvement in
that because it's actually
given some positions on it it's made
this process
i'm going to say straightforward but
more straightforward than it might have
otherwise been
it's a big process doing a 10-year thing
and then we've got a lot of other
consultations going on so there's been a
lot of work
so in fact yeah thank you tim i've
enjoyed
working with you over these last couple
of days now the next part comes which is
getting out there amongst our community
and letting them know about it and
there'll be engagement opportunities
which the team
alistair and the team are working
through how we might
do what we've done in the past which is
supermarkets and others so they'll be in
touch with you about opportunities there
the cd document um has been uploaded
into the document resource center there
so you've got any comments on that
welcome back
obviously there will be some revision
then there based on our conversation
on our discussion here but on principle
i think most things
are are included there in anticipation
so welcome anything back there but
thanks everyone
anyone else wish to speak um rudy
step
you had the pain then
[Laughter]
just look i want to reiterate everything
that's been said there just a couple of
things really yeah thank you mr mayor
for your chairmanship i think it's been
you've hurried us along while keeping it
um
as best you could without upsetting
anybody and i think i honestly i think
it's probably
some of the best chairmanship around the
plan
that i that i've seen for a while and to
my colleagues i've
i don't think we've ever agreed to
disagree
without at least one little session
through our session
of a hot under the collar and we didn't
even do that and that is and this is a
10-year plan so
thank you all for the cooperation of
everybody and i agree with wendy i think
it's
down to us even though we grumble and
moan and
down to the briefings that we've had
that made that happen
thanks david right
i just better just make sure i continue
to cheer it so
um good on you kirsten um yes as the
counselor who's known for asking the
most questions
um it was absolutely each one having the
government's um system i thought that
was
brilliant i could go through it really
carefully and
i had most of my questions answered and
then all i had to do was focus on the
key ones that i
hadn't quite got so that sped things up
an awful lot for me it made it a lot
clearer i want to make special
mention this year because i've always
given them a hard time with the drainage
unit they did an
excellent job this year i didn't find a
single mistake um so i just would love
to pass that on to the drainage unit
because they've always had a bit of a
hard time coming
so thank you very much to everyone for
the excellent information presented
and and i agree with councillor atkins
and it's been the simplest the most
straightforward and
haven't lost any sleep over this one
it's been very very
um it's actually it's kind of been fun
to work as a team and to make sure that
we're heading in the right direction
are we
um
[Music]
just like to say um thank you and just
write and reply
germans your last ltp with us
so thank you for helping us and you
promised you would
and thank you for helping us lean this
in the position that we can present to
our community and i think
you can go out you can held very high
this is a
given all we've been through to present
this to our community in the way
with the numbers that we're projecting
that's it's pretty respectable really
and and as we've mentioned prudent and
responsible particularly when we hear
the challenges other councils have got
at keeping years down i think this will
land very well with our community but
we'll we will hear
very shortly i don't want to preempt
that too much but jim
um thank you for your leadership through
this we really appreciated it and
obviously we you're with us for another
month but um
it's uh it's been a privilege to work
with you through this period quick ride
of reply if i
couldn't yes yes steal you'll write a
reply um
can't say thanks and and thanks to you
guys uh it has been a pretty hard
journey and you
you have uh contributed to those
workshops and helped
shape a direction and have stuck pretty
well to it and that's given us good
guidance
and confidence to be able to go away and
say well that's what they want to see
how we're going to deliver that and
we've tried to do that to the best of
our ability so we've actually
uh worked continue to work well as a
team and i think that's great it
certainly was one of my key objectives
on retirement is to ensure that we
landed an lpp
that we were comfortable with and
was robust and gave you a good base and
hopefully
for jim harland when he comes on board
that continues on and i'm sure it will
so thank you
thank you for your kind words to our
staff they i really do appreciate
the feedback and compliment you provide
them
when that's due so much appreciate it
and
it's only just the hard work of turning
that on to something that makes sense
for our community which
the the resource document you'll see
there
um any number that doesn't look right
there's
graphs they'll all need to be refreshed
and redone and
checked but um the sense of the words is
what we're
what we're hoping you'll be
happy to receive your comments so thank
you thank you
but at this point i'll um declare our
meeting to put that you have to
i'll put the i'll put the motion all
those in favor please say aye
contrary declare that carried so with
that i'll close our meeting
um and look forward to seeing you next
tuesday if not before